[Musique]
certains jours reste gravé dans nos
mémoires
ce matin là au centaure la famille de
sylvain vaitilingom a fait le
déplacement car leur fils major de sa
promotion reçoit le prix départemental
de l'excellence la ccr et le cnar mme
partenaires de cette opération ont pris
tour à tour la parole pour féliciter ce
jeune cuisinier volontaires qui a gagné
une formation chez lenôtre à paris au
liban et que nous avons des jeunes qui
sont remplis de talent mais qui parfois
sont un peu timides qui n'osent pas et
c'est le problème de la jeunesse de
façon générale et donc il faut susciter
il faut pousser chacun d'entre eux aller
le plus loin possible
justement exprimé les talents que qu'il
a en lui pas une seule absence sur toute
sa formation les meilleures notes de sa
promotion et un talent qui met en valeur
les produits réunionnais sylvain veille
si lingots mais d'un calme déconcertant
malgré tous ces regards sur son plat du
jour
wang major déjà ben il faut s'investir
il faut être motivé aussi à beaucoup il
ya le savoir-faire bien sûr et surtout
beaucoup le savoir être donc faut être
présent pas de retard pas d'absence il
faut
il faut s'investir il faut apprendre
écouter et apprécier aussi la cuisine de
très bons c'est pour les élèves pour
l'extérieur aussi parce que je pense que
on a taux de réussite de l'année
dernière 95% et je pense que nos élèves
ne respecte pas la rue ils partent sont
convoitées dans le monde et je pense
qu'à travers ce prix d'excellence
l'extérieur même ici à la réunion
ils ne voient plus confiance aux
centaures et dire qu on est vraiment un
centre reconnu dans le monde
le chemin ne sera pas facile pour ce
jeune cuisinier mais ce passage par la
mobilité lui offrira probablement de
quoi devenir demain un chef
[Musique]